- I didn't go into this to prove
anything to anybody other than myself.
There was a lot of raised eyebrows.
All those that could raise their eyebrows.
(laughter)
When they heard I was going to do this.
Pop star who's married to a footballer,
really going to do a clothing line?
When someone kicks me, I
try hard to get up again.
- She an English entrepreneur,
fashion designer, model, and singer.
She rose to fame with the all
female pop group Spice Girls.
In the past decade she's become an
internationally recognized
fashion icon and designer.
She's Victoria Beckham, and here's my
take on her top 10 rules for success.
Number one is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best.
Also as she's talking,
if she says something
that really impacts you, please leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so that other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat orchestral music)
- It is what I always wanted to do,
fashion really is my passion, it's what
I love to do, it's what I have to do.
I love what I do, I don't
consider what I do as my job.
I always say well it's almost like,
it almost feels like a hobby that
has done really really
well because I love it.
A lot of people don't associate work with
enjoying themselves and
they don't associate
work with being their
passion whereas I really do.
But fashion was always my passion,
and I'm living a dream, I really am,
and I wake up every
morning and I pinch myself.
I'm very very lucky, I feel very blessed,
so I would say right now is definitely
where I feel comfortable, I believe that
I'm competing in an arena where
actually, I feel like I'm good at this,
I've got a long way to go, there's lots
of things that I want to do, I was
never going to be the best singer or
the best dancer, and that was okay.
I had four other people with me.
- You did quite well at it through.
- I didn't do bad, but I hid behind
the others a little bit, but I really
feel that I had something to give,
I feel that I have a point of view,
and I have a lot to say, and it's
great when you find something that
you think that you're okay at.
I say the best advice that I could
give anybody is to work for somebody else.
Work for another brand, and when I
was working with Rock & Republic,
when I was working with Linda Farrow
which is a sunglasses brand that
I was working for, I was like a sponge.
You can take that opportunity to learn
so much about the
industry, and I did that.
They were licensed deals that I had
back in the day, and I worked with
Koti, the fragrance company, the fragrance
house as well, and I learned so much.
When I was in a position
to bring everything
in house and own everything myself and
create a team that would do this
with me, I felt ready to do it.
Though I didn't really, I didn't
go to fashion school, I was working
for other people and I learned an
enormous amount in a
very short space of time.
I always want to better myself.
I don't consider myself, sorry, I don't
consider other designers competition.
For me, my competition is
me from the season before.
I'm very ambitious, I always want
to better myself, I never sit back and
say wow, look at what I've achieved.
To be honest I wish that I could do that
because I should do that, but I always
just want to better myself, what's next,
how can I improve, how
can I make myself better?
I'm a perfectionist, but in
the nicest sense of the word.
I was going to say that I think there are
a lot of celebrities that have a lot
of clothing lines or perfumes, and I
think that what I'm
doing is very different,
I'm not just putting my
name on different products.
I'm very involved, I go to the factories,
I see the denim, I work with the people
that I'm working with, and I think that's
what makes what I'm doing
very very different.
I'm creative director,
I've been working on
everything that I'm working on now
for the last seven years, this has
been a long, long process and that's
how long it's taken to get it right.
I'm not just saying I'm Victoria Beckham,
I'm going to put my name
on a bottle of perfume.
I'm actually creating that, I'm designing
the bottle, I'm designing the label and
that's what I love,
that's my fourth child.
When I initially started up the brand,
I didn't put too much pressure on myself,
I didn't go into this to prove
anything to anybody other than myself.
I was very focused, I didn't try
and do everything at once, for quite
a few seasons I stopped to just
perfecting the dress, I didn't
want to run before I could walk.
It's very important to be focused
and do what I was doing very very well
and move on and do more when my
team was in the position to do that.
I think that it's about
keeping things focused.
I'm not trying to do too much.
- You didn't care what people
say, what people think of you.
- No, I mean I gave up a long long time
worrying and concerning myself over that.
I care what people say about what I do
professionally, I care
about what my customer says.
That's what I do care about because
why do I do what I do, I do what I do
because I love women, I
want to empower women,
I want women to feel good, I want them
to feel beautiful, and so I care about
what my customer thinks because I
want to give her what she wants,
but generally speaking, I don't
focus too much on anything negative.
When I first started, so 10 seasons ago,
I had a room at a hotel in New York,
and I did sometimes one
on one presentations,
sometimes as a group of people,
sometimes it was one on one, and I
did that for four days
to fashion press, buyers.
I literally would talk
through the collection,
I had 10 dresses and I'd sit there and
I'd talk about the dress and the dress
would come in on a model and I'd unzip
the dress and talk about the corsetry
and the inspiration and the fabrics.
Sometimes I'd be talking
for hours on end to
people that didn't actually
even speak English.
(laughter)
They were foreign retailers, but I
just like to talk, so I'd be talking away
and really wanted people to understand the
concept really and
understand what I was doing.
I remember it was 3 o'clock in the morning
the night before the
show and I was standing,
there was a florist actually in the hotel
and I was standing there in my slippers
trying to decide on the flowers.
I didn't have a stylist or great
hair and makeup, things have come
such a long way since those days.
I think right at the beginning, I didn't
know what people were going to think,
there was a lot of raised eyebrows.
All those that could raise their eyebrows.
(laughter)
When they heard I was going to do this.
Pop star who's married to a footballer
really going to do a clothing line?
A lot of people had preconceptions.
I didn't go out to prove
anybody wrong, I just
wanted to prove to myself
that I could do it.
- And what comes to is your determination
at all cost to actually succeed, I mean
is that a message that
you hope comes across
to kids because a lot of kids think that
people just become famous
overnight don't they?
- Yeah, I think that people don't realize
that it's all about hard work, I mean
I worked hard when I was at school,
I've always had it in my personality
to want to succeed, even when it was
I want to do my homework right.
But yeah, I'm one of these people,
when someone kicks me, I
try hard to get up again.
Because I know what I want to do, I love
what I do at the end of the day, I know
that I'm putting myself up for criticism,
I'm very much aware of
that, but I love what I do.
I think everybody has crazy moments of
self-doubt, and I think that an element
of that is probably quite important.
It's about creative visualization and
challenging yourself, but always
staying very positive, and there's
nothing wrong with having a second
little person sitting on your shoulder
making sure that you are remaining humble
and that you're remaining appreciative
of everything that you have and
everything that you've achieved.
You should definitely not waste
too much time being negative in
any way, it's about positive thinking,
positive energy, and fighting
if you need to fight.
I mean my team is so great, we're a
small team, but we're growing and
they're all incredibly talented,
passionate, focused, I also think
it's important to enjoy the people
that you're working with as well.
We have a lot of fun every day,
but they're passionate, they love
what they do, they believe in my
brand and what I'm creating.
I have the same team that I had
when I first started over six years ago.
I really encourage my team to grow
with me as I grow as a brand as well.
Yes, I bring in a few new people,
but it's about giving people that
work with me the opportunity to
grow within the company as well.
I have a few people that started
out with me as interns that now have
high up jobs in marketing,
press, and sales as well.
It's a really nice family
atmosphere at work.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Kris Dunlop
asked me to, so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next, leave it down in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did
you learn from Victoria in this video,
what's the thing that you're going to
apply immediately to your life or
your business after watching this clip?
Super curious to find out, leave it in the
comments, I'm going to
join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Sandra from Kitsch Cakes, Sandra thank
you so much for picking
up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making those awesome
tribute cookies, they looked amazing
and they tasted even better and I
really really really
appreciate your support.
- Tada!
This is what we've made for you.
In tribute to your #Believe, here we go.
- Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.